this morning Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo is in North Korea where he could
meet with kim jeong-hoon he landed in
Pyongyang overnight for the first time
since President Trump met Kim at a
summit in Singapore last month
Pompeyo said he's looking to fill in
some details on North Korea that Korea's
commitment to denuclearize CBS News
senior national security contributor
Michael Morell was deputy director and
acting director of the CIA good morning
Mike Howell morning great to be with you
guys so the North has continued to
update its nuclear program even after
the meeting that President Trump had
with Kim what is a reasonable
expectation for the outcome of this
meeting there are three things Alex that
has to happen one is North Korea has to
make a declaration of its nuclear
capabilities
numbers of weapons where they are how
much fissile material they have where
those production villages are who the
scientists are how many there are a
complete and truthful declaration then
there has to be a negotiation for how
they dismantle all of that and what we
give in return right and at what time
table both of those things happen and
then the last piece is how do you verify
going forward that they live up to their
agreement and don't start cheating right
three pieces I would hope that the
secretary would come back with that
understanding on both sides that that's
what has to happen here and a time to a
specific timetable for the declaration
when are they going to hand us that
piece of paper I would hope it's two or
three months from now so as you
mentioned we still don't have an account
e of what North Korea has the Defense
Intelligence Agency came out with an
assessment saying that Kim has no plans
of denuclearization so what does
progress look like in that scenario so I
think the Defense Intelligence Agency's
assessment is just that I don't think
it's based on any hard reporting it's
what they think it's based on history
like most North Korea analysts believe
that Kim will not give up his entire
program there are a handful of North
Korean analysts who believe that maybe
we are in a different spot now maybe he
has changed maybe he is willing to give
them up right so what what secretary
Pompeo is doing here is really testing
that
and the declaration will be the first
test write the declaration if it's
complete and truthful we'll have an
indication that maybe he is serious if
he lies in the Declaration and we'll
know if last we have a pretty good
understanding of what he has including
some things that he's never acknowledged
to the international community before so
that declaration is that we know how
much he hasn't told us don't know right
you don't know try this this will be a
real test of whether he is serious or
not like we're getting leaks out of the
government suggesting you know
suggesting that the North Koreans aren't
changing here why why are those leaks
coming out what's going on in the
government about this so I would imagine
that there is some concern among
officials particularly on the policy
side that the president will only
negotiate on what Kim and the North
Koreans have before acknowledged to the
International Atomic Energy Agency I
acknowledged in the international
community what these leaks I think are
trying to do is say there's a bigger
program here make sure you cover it all
and trying to box the president in a
little bit let me ask you something as
former acting director of the CIA the
president was speaking in Montana
yesterday he was mocking his critics for
saying that President Putin is KGB and
this and that you know what Putin is
fine what is your reaction about
Vladimir Putin is a trained intelligence
officer he is trained to spot the
vulnerabilities in individuals and then
take advantage of those vulnerabilities
right my view is he has done that with
President Trump since day one there is
going to be a lot of attention paid to
the upcoming meeting between Vladimir
Putin and Trump including their
one-on-one Mike Morell thank you